I think the government are deliberately
messing with property owners right now
and it is really ticking me off they're
announcing things scaring everybody then
unannouncing things dropping in
legislation without properly talking
about it being hard to know what the
rules are but then if you break the
rules literally can send you to prison
so I wanted to give you a little
condensed update as to some of the new
legislations in the property Market
because if you're buying properties
right now and you don't know the laws
and the legislations then beware because
you can they'll find you or they'll
literally take you to prison let me tell
you something
changed
changed or announced recently that they
were going to change the rules with
energy performance certificates let me
explain I'm Gonna Give You context to
this and tell you what they said they
were going to do and then tell you what
they actually did okay so they said
go from 2025
every house in England that was rented
out had to be energy performance
certificate of a c or or or or or or or
or or above is it is it above or is it
below
a b or c right so in other words every
house
has to be insulated double triple glazed
maybe solar panels really energy and
it's this whole you know they're saying
everyone needs to drive an electric car
everyone needs so a lot of landlords got
really cheesed off with this and decided
forget that I'm selling so loads of
people put the house up for sale and
because loads of people at the house up
for sale all these landlords and these
irritated landlords put the hustle for
sale then that brought the property
prices down because basic supply and
demand if there's a lot of houses on for
sale then there's a lot of properties to
pick from so houses drop so that was one
of the things that cause houses to drop
this year is that a good thing or a bad
thing it depends on whether you're
buying or whether you were selling I was
buying so for me you could argue it's a
good thing but let me tell you something
really interesting they then said
actually we're going to bring this rule
in not in 2025. we're going to bring it
in in 2028 to give people time to
prepare to give people time to do the
changes to their houses that they have
to do by law
so some landlords are selling some
landlords are changing the house and
spending money on it well guess what
they just announced 48 hours ago
actually
we're not going to bring it in at all
you know what yeah we're not going to
make you change your EPC to see anymore
it's fine leave it as it is which is
like now has infuriated a lot of
landlords because they just sold the
house and they said I wouldn't have sold
the property if you if I've known you
weren't going to bring it in did they
know all along they were not going to
bring it in probably
same with electric cars they said that
they were gonna uh for I think it was
2030. they weren't going to allow any of
the manufacturers to build petrol diesel
cars and now they just went oh actually
it's 30 35. guaranteed they'll say but
before 30 35 oh actually it's never they
just want everybody to buy an electric
car and think oh I'm going to be forced
to anyway I may as well oh I'm gonna be
forced to get solar panels and I'm gonna
be forced to get my EPC down to a c
anyway I might as well do it and then
they got uh but but they know there's a
group of people that just won't do it
anyway so it's just really really really
annoying and from my perspective as I
say it's not personally it's not hit me
do I think it's a good thing that
they've scrapped it probably I don't
think they should have ever announced it
in the first place I don't know what's
gonna happen but so what how does this
affect you well
it's just like it always was if it's an
e or below i a b c d e you're fine if
it's an F or a g then you can't rent it
out but that's always been the case
because F's and G's are not going to be
you know habitable properties anyway so
the EPC thing that's what's going on
government's agenda crazy absolutely
mind-boggling that they're just messing
like a emotional roller coaster with
landlords next thing I want to talk
about this as well this is really
important I want to talk about prison
one of the things that just scan me is a
lot of the rules that they are bringing
in slash proposing to bring in the
penalty of not complying is prison which
to me seems crazy like when they um said
they were going to change the EPC rules
do you know the consequence of not
getting your EPC upgraded was was going
to be prison
that to me just seems really extreme
there's another thing
they have just announced they're going
to bring in as from next month and this
affects me directly do I think it's a
good thing or bad thing I'm actually I
could argue both ways but they're
bringing in as from next month in
October 2023 in this country they're
saying that if you have a holiday let or
an Airbnb property you cannot rent it
out without fire doors and
um smoke alarms now again I don't think
this is a terrible thing are they
actually going to bring it in I guess
until Lord comes in we just don't know
but I think they're probably well
um as it happens I don't think this is
necessarily a super bad thing I'll argue
both ways I think that it is going to be
that let's start with the bad the bad is
obvious it's just going to be an extra
expense to landlords or people that
control properties that are running them
in short stay there it's an extra
respect it's five dollars how much is a
fire door like 90 pound you've not gonna
go get the whole house fire doors you've
just got to get fired on the bedrooms
and on the uh and where they would be
existing so um like exit route so you
know it's probably going to cost at
least a few hundred pounds depending on
the property that you've got to get
Fireballs also the alarms I mean as it
happens most of my properties that I
have I run with fire doors anyway
because I think they're better doors
they're sturdier doors and it makes
sense all of my hmos or fire doors of
course
um so they're bringing that in I mean
the goods the only good I can think of
is that
it slightly brings a higher barrier to
entry to the market with people wanting
to do Airbnb because Airbnb is just it
for the last few years it's literally
just been you can rent anything on
Airbnb if you've got a shed in the
garden you can just stick it on Airbnb
now a big part of my market is renting
properties out of short sale X not just
Airbnb but also booking.com and many
other online travel agents so the fact
that they've slightly legislated this
industry means there's probably going to
be a lot of cowboy competition a lot of
people that would be doing
the would be in the business but
probably not running the business
properly
um that will maybe drop out always gonna
be a lot of people that were thinking of
should I put my spare room on Airbnb and
then they're like oh there's legislation
I don't really understand it oh what
kind of alarms do I need oh you know
what forget it which means that then
going back to supply and demand is going
to mean that my property is on my book
so I guess that's the positive negative
is you know legislations always
um practically it just means a little
bit of extra
um time and money they're also saying
you're going to have to test things in
the kitchen so if you've got like
microwaves and Kettles they'll need to
be pack tested it doesn't cost a lot of
money I think you might be talking 20 30
pounds
um you know for a pack test but it's
just a little bit more hassle which
again for me as a business owner who's
seriously about running my business it's
not really a big deal but two the person
is thinking should I just stick my spare
room on Airbnb it's gonna sound like a
lot of hassle it's going to put them off
meaning that I've got less competition
uh so so have you so I don't know if
it's a good thing or bad thing but I
wanted to just address it in this video
to let you know that those are some of
the things that's happening with the
legislation please do educate yourself
in property keep up to date with the
legislation because you can make a load
of money and then potentially end up
going to prison which would suck and the
fact that they make it so easy to go to
prison is is just ridiculous I might do
a whole video on things you can do as a
property investor that would end up
sending you to prison and I'll just tell
you all the different stuff you could do
to send you to prison because it's crazy
how easy it is to go to prison when
you're a business owner an entrepreneur
I mean geez if you've got like a HMO and
you don't have it license when you
should have a license
and then they find out they'll find you
and then ultimately you can go to prison
for that or if somebody dies in the
property maybe that's a little bit more
reasonable and you don't have five doors
that could be a prison sentence you
might say oh yeah you should go to
prison but again like if you're an
ignorant landlord or an ignorant
property investor and you just didn't
know
um and you just put doors that you
thought look nice and you don't know the
law
ignorance is not Bliss so I would
suggest that you really study this
industry there's a lot of opportunities
in the market interest rates have dipped
slightly I think there's a bit more
confidence in the market from lenders
some bridging lenders have recently said
that they're going to be loaning out 90
loan to value
um Finance on bridging loans which means
there's a bit of confidence in the
market so I think it's a great
opportunity you know the market is right
but do it right get educated and get
around people that are doing property so
you can bounce ideas off the right
people I'm going to be running a crash
course a property investors crash course
next month if you'd like to come along
and join me
at the property investors crash course
tickets are one pound learn how to do it
right get the foundations right from the
beginning get people around you that are
going to advise you to do it in the
correct way and I look forward to
hopefully helping you build a property
portfolio become financially independent
and I'll see you real soon Link in BIO
get booked on tickets are just one pound